not saying you in particular but for
like in general based on your experience
I think that like uh the the term Pimpin
has got a a bad stigma to it obviously
but like I do feel like what you said
earlier about structure you're like yo
I've created structure so I I can take
it how I give it
um would you say that that is the main
purpose of somebody who holds that title
not saying yourself I just mean in
general someone run that back to me
again
so the purpose of a pimp you know in a
girl's life who is that why are you so
curious about that because I'm just
curious like
if I'm not saying you I mean in general
would you say the main purpose of that
would be structure
structure you know and I'll say this man
for what I've always seen the game as
and especially sitting back now and
looking in on it
it's I feel like
it's just coming together with somebody
that really understands what you're
doing because like I've said before and
I'll give I'll use you as an example
you work a regular 95 right let's say
you work let's just say yeah okay okay
fair enough yeah you just you work a
regular 95 or whatever fair enough and
you come home
and you know you want a hot meal maybe
lay down with your chick you know watch
some Netflix or something get rubbed
don't do what you do you know get get up
and get ready to do your thing again in
the morning correct could you accept
when you come in and you know you coming
from long day of work you getting in the
shower she's getting out the shower to
get ready to go to work to go and [ __ ]
with some tricks could you accept that
could I if I was working a nine to five
yeah could you accept that
just you're coming home every day and
that's what she's doing
uh it would depend on how I met you
you're in love with her oh man come on
I'm in love with her you're in love with
her you're in the whole city you're in a
whole relationship with her
if I was just a normal dude normal Joe
Schmo probably not
I don't know I don't you have to think
about what I'm saying here okay do I
think I would give a [ __ ] yes I would
give a [ __ ] yes relationship yes sir yes
I would probably not be okay with it she
was turning tricks yes yes I mean would
you be okay with her leaving every night
you don't know what she's doing
you just know she's getting some money
if I was a joke I would say yeah I would
probably be like what the [ __ ] going
on here yeah you know what I'm saying
yes how many you have to think about it
that's even though okay you're a rare
one of one obviously my bad but you have
to think about how many other people no
no no no I'm telling you that if I was
just a normal guy I would give a [ __ ]
I'd be like what the [ __ ] are you doing
and that's my point like a [ __ ]
is going to give a [ __ ] so there's a lot
of chicks that aren't gonna stop doing
what they're doing you know what I'm
saying but they still want to they're a
woman they still want affection they
still yearn for partner they still yearn
for that nobody wants to be alone the
biggest baddest [ __ ] that'll sit
there and say oh I'm independent I'm
about want somebody you have a [ __ ] if
it's a [ __ ] a cat a dog like
motherfucker's gonna want something some
sort of affection some sort of yeah or
friendship something some type of a
situationship relationship doesn't
matter they're gonna want it because in
this in this world nobody's built to be
alone
um that's how I feel nobody to be alone
and I think everybody knows that deep
down inside they just can't find the
[ __ ] words
you know what I'm saying because that's
when it really it stems to to me
everybody one and everybody wants to be
wanted not needed so you're saying
essentially essentially
companionship
but it's also obviously a business
relationship I mean when you're in that
wouldn't you want some type of
compensation
fair enough
I mean damn like if I'm gonna put up
with all these guys running through it
I'm gonna need a little compensation
what you're gonna sit there and say and
do like I said either either
that [ __ ] it isn't for everybody that's
fair and it seems like it's been a it's
a it's a dying game man it's a dying
breach you got to pick something else up
yeah well like nowadays you got like uh
you know
you got like guys like uh tiger like
launching like only fans agencies like I
mean [ __ ] Adam manages girls on only
fans you know shout out to him getting
it get get into it amen